and now here are the nominees for Best
Documentary Short subject in the absence
assumption and Gary hyung Suk Kong
learning to skateboard in a war zone if
you're a girl
Bell dicing the and Elena Andre Achieva
life overtakes me John hattis and
Christine Samuelson st. Louis Superman
Rita mudra and Sandy Cohen walk run
cha-cha Laura Nixon Colette's and stick
and the winner is learning the
skateboard in a war zone if you are girl
first Oscar and nomination for killed
and Elena Andre
[Applause]
[Music]
oh my god I know I am Frank Capra you
guys remember Frank Capra handed me a
student Academy Award in 1977 and I
thought I'd skipped the hard part I
thought I would then go on to make
movies and if I hadn't had that
encouragement at my back back then I
wouldn't have been able to withstand the
last four four decades in this business
I want to thank a any indie films and
Molly Thompson grain media to add a
Mitch I know the man behind the women
the brilliance my Lisa Rinzler
cinematographer and Mary mannhart editor
extraordinaire to zama and Tammy Ossie
our number-one girl crew I've been
working in Afghanistan since 2005 and
this movie is my love letter to the
brave girls of that country to get to
Capra from here took a whole lot of not
quitting and teachers the kind I strive
to be at NYU film school in the kind of
teachers at skata span the school at the
heart of the film they teach girls
courage to raise your hand to say I am
here I have something to say and I'm
gonna take that ramp don't try to stop
me thank you very much
[Applause]